hey how's it going bros my name is
PewDiePie and welcome to pants on fire
it's a little show that we shot while in
Seattle four packs and we got to strap
down our friends for a lie-detector test
and ask them the tough questions it's
the first kind of higher production
thing we did for rebel mode I'm really
excited for it and I hope you will enjoy
do you like having cream on your face hi
me again
are you into kinky [ __ ] I mean I got a
bone
[Music]
are you PewDiePie no yes yes come on
dude truth okay do you think you're the
best youtuber in the world yes really
you either mystical [ __ ] you heard it
here first folks I'm the best YouTube
channel ever every youtuber thinks
they're the best
yeah that's every youtuber things are
hot [ __ ] did you dye your hair because
you were jealous of me and Marik I don't
know what to answer did you dye your
hair cuz you're jealous of me and mark
no Joey says no no [ __ ] way
[ __ ] you just my hair but not wanted a
piece you want anything I'm covering up
your wanted you think I look like you
no one was you hit me you son of a [ __ ]
it was a lie no what's the smell like
okay fine okay fine always good I want
to be I want it I want to be like you
jack
I just want to be like you my face burns
it really hurts this is what is in this
do you copy filthy Frank no channel no
does he do that I think the answer
somewhere inside this machine she like
one of those DIY channels I have to
cover up the copying that's a truth line
true maybe you get half a pie then oh
yeah do you hate me yes yeah do you like
having cream on your face
yeah really you're into this wrong with
you I guess I am
hi me again are you into kinky [ __ ] I
mean what are you I'm Thai I'm tied up
I'm creamed I got a bone do you have a
boner right now no I wish want to check
that bro come huh dreams hi dude do you
think you saved Ken's channel right
there don't like is it not dead hey yeah
here this for myself how you doing did
you save Ken's champ yeah please I think
you need some pie
I thought we I thought we were friends
[Music]
joke's on you [ __ ] this has been beauty
live stakes
[Music]